today canat sisters I'm going to show
you a video clip of our pray mat getting
printed in Turkey you can see it with
your own eyes we are sending over 20,000
more prayer mats to be printed why cuz
we ordered a year and a half go if you
guys remember you donated 10,000 it's
all gone done got 10,000 plus people
learned how to play Salah by the pr mat
now we're sending to print
20,000 why because we are going to be
send them out to di tables mass and
people have been individually ordering
them all around the world Jennifer in
Canada Catalin in USA James in the UK
born Muslim and new Muslims here's the
video watch it today come sisters donate
in the link in the description box below
I've paid the first deposit it's
£126,000 for 20,000 play mats I paid the
first half we need the second half of
61,500 give whatever you can and we want
to insh send them off to get printed
here is the video you can see for
yourself inah give whatever you can it
will be imagine teaching someone Salah
they know Salah every time they recite
Surah fa you get the benefits I have
recited Sur F 68,000 times since I
became a Muslim imagine the rewards of
the one who taught me these guided pray
Ms help people to learn how to pray
Salah and worship their lord and donate
the description Bo below